where was theing controller that's like
45 45 45 did that come down right now
echo echo chamber Echo chamber Echo
chamber Echo chamber Echo chamber and
then like copy that copy that we're just
going to tell you everything you already
want to
[Laughter]
[Music]
hear visualize this you're a woman
you're on a riding lawn mower okay like
one of those John De John Deere ones one
of those John Deere ones okay and then
you get hit by the wing of an airplane
and killed what what the [__] literally
that's what happened she's just mowing
her line and the [__] plane crashes
into her Happy Tree Friends episode or
something was it just the wing or was it
the whole air the wing is what hit her I
mean like is it just the wing that fell
out of nowhere or was a whole airplane
it was the whole airplane they just
taken off and like she was riding this
thing next to an airport Runway can I
ask a question oh oh is that a
situational awareness thing or is that a
freak accident I mean it seems
situational awareness it it seems like a
bothie and does this
reinforce or go against that women
aren't good drivers I think it
reinforces it it depends if there was a
female pilot in the plane oh even
double and and even worse if oh [__] I
thought that was a Runway I'm sorry I
can tell you though it was a man driving
the airplane and he was driving it well
okay yeah okay so it's not his fault
it's a good riddle but then they were
both Chinese
oh they were not both Chinese that was
the great reveal I could see that in in
the UK so it's opposite sides of the
road holy [__] dude so that means the
guy crashed on the other end they just
didn't report it oh this is in Oklahoma
oh so the roads are on yeah oppos got it
she's riding a lawn more right she's
cutting grass cutting grass oh she's
cutting cutting grass gets struck by the
wing of a small airplane assass yeah and
then um the the pilot cuz if she's
riding um like lawnmower and it's like a
big old Delta flight it'll just go over
you would think and there's usually no
grass at those kind of airports you ever
see that though and you're like I do
wonder how they cut this
grass right it's not like overgrown
grass outside the airport my question is
how far away does the plane have to be
until you realize that like oh that's
coming right at me what if she's facing
the other way and then the lawn is loud
she's got those ear muffs on that's true
she might be listening to some Beats by
Dre noise counseling he's like get out
of the way and then she's all like
[__] listening to Taylor Swift or
whatever the [__] that's why you need
transparency mode you know you got to
double tap that so you hear the outside
oh yeah I like those you do I use those
yeah where like you can still kind of
hear out there's a a new update for the
airpods through iOS 17 where it if you
it's it has awareness of where you are
and what environment so that you it'll
automatically switch for you I had to
give my airpods away what cuz it could
fit my ear and it kept falling out I was
getting pissed no this one shut up
sounds like the the feature where they
changed the brightness and I'm always
like [__] off stop changing my [__]
brightness my battery I I do turn it off
and it still turns back on well I don't
know what to say your airpod doesn't fit
only on the left ear yeah so I gave them
to somebody I don't like it when my
airpods can listen to the outside cuz I
feel like it's going to damage my ears
did you only give away one airpod No I
gave I just I was mad I do you have do
you have a cool airpod
story okay you know you know the answer
was no moving on so the the pilot told
investigators he saw uh the woman after
touching down and he tried to P you he
saw her head no no oh it wasn't a lift
up it was a touchdown touching down
right and then he tries to pull up to
fly over her but then he saw her get hit
by the wing oh oh my God so she came out
of [__] nowhere well no not really he
just sort of landed and then he was
aware that she was there and then he's
like ah [__] so he tries to like pull
the nose up so the so he Highlander her
a he closed like you should have jumped
out of the thing she didn't know he was
coming you got to do one of these dude
oh my God that's [__] that's why can't
she turn how come she kept going
straight if that was me I would have
just turn that's manslaughter I mean
those things are pretty
slow turn so that's what they're
inv
holy [__] investigating whether any
charges could be filed against the pilot
like did did the pilot do anything wrong
or was this like an unavoidable accident
where was the [__] controller that's
like 45 45 45 did that come down right
now echo echo chamber Echo chamber I
think they're looking at the air I don't
know if they're looking at the ground
Echo chamber Echo chamber Echo chamber
and they're like copy that copy that
we're just going to tell you everything
you already want to
hear yeah it's clear for Runway yeah
roadways clear that's exactly what I
want to hear thank you copy that for
that long and the weather's great right
now with a smooth Breeze at 76° F we did
not Chum off her head damn that's a sad
way to go that's [__] up yeah it's
pretty sad this is also under
investigation they want to make sure
this is kind of weird um they want to
check whether the woman woman was
wearing reflective clothing or if she
even saw the airplane so they can blame
her first maybe you're supposed to wear
reflective clothing well yeah otherwise
you're asking for it doesn't everybody
on the charmac wear reflective clothing
usually when you see them that's right
with the neon vest the guy that does
this [__] cuz even the crosswalk lady
got the reflective [__] on even the even
the baggage handlers wear that that's
right yeah you have to so are we going
to victim blame I think I think we
should think we just did I think we did
I think the pilot is the victim here
yeah cuz how traumatic is it for that
guy poor guy yeah to kill someone yeah
the it's hard enough to die for it but
to live with it yeah and we're losing
Pilots by the day dude by The Day You
Can't Get Enough Pilots out here and now
this guy's probably not going to fly
anymore cuz he's scared he's going to
kill he's discouraging other people who
are prespective pilot we shouldn't have
high mentality guys it sucks for her am
I
right I'll scratching my head yeah I
just hopefully it was a fast death it
says it was very
slow arduous damn it just it just barely
nicked her
artery yeah I don't know it's
uncomfortable says she survived the
first and he turned around and came back
oh stupid finished the job yeah yeah
yeah it gave all those details we we
know that these news articles always do
that does it have a picture of the
lawnmower by chance what was the brand
it was was the brand is that the one
they sell at Cost yeah and the pattern
cutting the grass what kind of pattern
was it cuz there is a pattern you got to
follow dude you got to go outside and
then go in exactly that's rough to be a
passenger in the plane and seeing that
yeah they have it worse sir sir there's
somebody there's somebody I just think
that's like
one of the most shocking things that
could ever happen I just I just do know
killing someone in a vehicle holy [__]
in an airplane I don't even think they
fly that low we had we had an article
last session about a dude who jumps out
he's skydiving right he jumps out of a
plane the skydiver I mean the plane the
pilot starts to [__] go downwards and
then decapitates him oh like the the
same plane he jumped out of yeah I think
that's way more likely than [__] this
dude yeah that's true yeah like this is
more likely to decapitate a skyver
jumping out of your own look he's a good
pilot bro was the pilot just like he
like as soon as the guy leaves he's like
all right we're going home immediately
yeah he just [__] started his nose
dive right away decapitated him well I
mean that's during extreme sports this
is just a regular day's work John Deere
is Extreme having maintaining good
habits for her household she just
cleaning her house pretty much I wonder
how often that's happened and like the
person was like whoa and like lived oh
yeah dude my brother was an air traffic
controller and he got out of it because
there too many close calls oh yeah you
were telling me the stress is like too
many like um moments where planes are
like maybe going to hit each other on
the runway just on the runway they need
AI for that cuz that's one of the most
stressful jobs in the world yeah let's
Bas the AI off them yeah and a lot of
them die so then they just do the same
[__] automatically really my bro could
have easily made like 100 plus K just to
do it right but he was like I'm done
with this [__] every day they like oh we
got to go this we got to go that okay
okay it's safe and then they're like
smoking he also said that um the wildest
[__] is like sometimes there's like
maybe one person working in the tower
and like a bunch of people are playing
Nintendo 64 in the back shut up really
seriously shut oh my God he said they
got like an N64 playing pilot Wings yeah
I don't know but like he was like yeah
this job is kind of wild I don't really
I guess you have to decompress in a way
right with a plug-in console in the back
oh oh my [__] god people need brakes
bro you can't work all day I'm just
surprised they don't have like a Xbox or
something more modern like I think they
like it okay I think they like it that's
like having a Pac-Man arcade system it's
they could at least have this kinges you
at least get this for 15 grand so
relatable is it 15 grand that's a lot
it's a lot yeah it was like 7K right
more importantly it says fear none on
there and that's just a
lie yeah we fear everyone everybody fear
none is is a bad thing I think it's
should be fear everybody don't double
down on it guy I I I am I actually am
afraid of most people I think and and
you respect some I yeah I respect less I
think
a